Good evening.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So I wanted to carry on with Rahula.
There are three discourses to Rahula.
The last one was given to him when he was 21 plus.
So you can't become a fully ordained monastic until you're 21.
Until you're 21, you are a samanera, a lower ordination.
And that one, he basically repeats the discourse on anatta, not self.
And it is said that after that, or shortly after that, or within a decent time after that, Rahula becomes fully liberated.
And the Buddha had the misfortune of having his son die before him.
as, in fact, both his main disciples, Sadiputa and Moggallana, died before him.
So a bit of sadness there.
But at the age of around about 18, he gives him a second discourse, and this is called the Greater Discourse to a Rahula.
So he's at Sarvati again, at the Jeta's Grove, and now to Pindika's Park.
That's the one he bought off Prince Jeta with a field of gold, it seems.
when it was morning the blessed one dressed and he'd taken his robe and bow set out for savati and rahula also dressed and taking his robe followed close behind the blessed one then the blessed one looked back and addressed venerable rahula rahula any kind of material form whatever whether past future or present internal or external gross or subtle inferior or superior
Far or near, all material form should be seen as it is with proper wisdom.
This is not mine.
This I am not.
It's not me.
And this is not myself.
Now.
uh rahula then says only material form blessed one and the buddha says no no there's also feeling perception uh habits of mental format or volitional formations and consciousness so those are your five aggregates if you remember but he didn't mention that he only mentioned the body so although he's put his material form he's obviously talking to rule about the body so the body past future present
Gross, my body, other people's body, the whole thing should be seen as it is.
This is not mine, doesn't belong to a me.
It's not me and it's not myself.
Now, Rahula says, who would go to town?
This he says to himself, who would go to town for alms today when personally admonished by the Blessed One?
Thus he turned back and sat down at the root of the tree, folding his legs crosswise, setting his body erect and establishing mindfulness.
So now it's obvious that at the age of 18, that dreadful devil and drugger's testosterone has got into him.
And the Buddha's noticed that he has an eye out for likable objects, shall we say.
And he's afraid that his son might return to the household life
And so he's now giving him, shall we say, instructions on how to overcome such desires.
Anyway, while he's sat there, Sariputta sees him.
And he says to him, Rahula, develop mindfulness of breathing.
When mindfulness of breathing is developed and cultivated, it is of great fruit and great benefit.
Okay.
Then when it was evening, the Venerable Rahula rose from meditation, went to see the Blessed One.
after paying homage, sat to one side.
Venerable sir, how is mindfulness of breathing developed and cultivated so it is of great fruit and great benefit?
And the Buddha replies, whatever internally belongs to oneself is solid, solidified and clung to
So in other words, he doesn't answer them.
And seemingly what seems to have happened, according to the commentaries, is that Sariputta, seeing him sat under a tree, sort of gave him a little bit of a push and said, why don't you try mindfulness of breathing, not realizing the Buddha had actually given him an object already, which was, of course, the body.
So now the Buddha goes through the four elements.
And so he starts off, of course, with the earth element.
Whatever internally belonging to oneself is solid, clung to.
Whatever is clung to, remember that, it's the upadana khanda, it's the five aggregates that are clung to, it's the clinging that's wrong, right?
The blame cannot be put on the five aggregates, that's just the psychophysical organism.
It's seeing it as a self, etc., which is the problem.
There is head hair, body hair, nails, teeth, skin, flesh, sinews, bone, bone marrow, kidneys, heart, liver, diaphragm, spleen, lungs, large intestine, small intestines, contents of the stomach, feces and whatever else internally belonging to oneself is solid, solidified and clung to.
That is the internal body.
earth element so and then he's and then he says um it should be seen simply as earth element that solidity should be seen just as solidity and when one sees it actually it's proper wisdom one becomes disenchanted right it loses its witchy craft over you so disenchanted with the other and makes the mind dispassionate towards it in other words doesn't get caught up in the body
So that's his first bit of advice.
Then he looks at the water element, whatever it is, internal water.
So whatever is watery and clung to bile, phlegm, pus, blood, sweat, fat, tears, grease, spittle, snot, oil of the joints, urine and whatever else there is.
He doesn't let you off, does he?
He gets down to the nitty gritty.
And again, he says, you have to see it with proper wisdom.
It's not mine.
This is not what I am.
And this is not myself.
And again, when you see this as it really is, you become disenchanted.
And your mind is dispassionate about what is the water element, actually.
Okay.
So dispassionate means non-attachment.
Then, of course, he says the fire element.
The fire element, he said, whatever is internally belonging to oneself is fire, fiery and clung to.
What is warmed and ages.
So the fact of aging is considered to be part of the heat and cold element and is consumed.
That by which is eaten, drunk, consumed and tasted gets completely digested and whatever else internally or belonging to oneself is fire, fiery and clung to.
And this again should be seen in the same way.
It's not me, not mine, etc.
And then we become dispassionate towards these things of the body and the mind cools.
Then there's the air element, of course.
So whatever internally belongs to air or airiness, up going winds and down going winds, winds in the belly, winds in the bowel, winds that course through the limbs.
in breath and out breath and whatever else belongs to the air or airy see so so lots of wind there both of the internal and external winds should be seen as it is it's just movement right it's just movement and when one sees it actually is then of course one becomes disenchanted and we arrive at dispassion non-attachment
And then the space element, which in Theravada Buddhism isn't actually an element as such, but it does become so, I think, in the Mahayana tradition.
But it's obviously there, space.
The space element is either internal or external.
So he says, whatever internally belongs to oneself is space or spatial or klung to and klung to.
Holes in the ears, the nostrils, door of the mouth,
the aperture whereby what is eaten, drunk, consumed and tasted gets swallowed and where it collects and whereby it is excreted from below.
Whatever else is internally belonging to oneself is space, spatial, et cetera.
And again, it's not mine.
I am not that, and it doesn't constitute a self.
In this way, we become disenchanted and dispassionate.
Now,
Having gone through a way of looking at the body by dividing it into its various elements, and therefore by that way of deconstructing it, losing that sense of attachment to our identity with it.
Having done that, he now goes through them again, only this time to show how they can be used.
So this is an instruction also to us.
Develop meditation that is like the earth.
when you develop meditation like the earth arisen agreeable and disagreeable contacts will not invade the mind and remain okay so there's your phrase with all these uh elements if they are developed if you develop meditation uh with that element as a as a simile or as a metaphor then you'll find that both what is agreeable what is attractive and what is not attractive
what is disagreeable, will not invade the mind.
So the mind here is sati, right?
Will not invade the mind and remain.
Actually, the mind here is what you're aware of.
So in other words, this is one way of keeping at bay those particular thoughts.
So just as people throw clean things and dirty things, excrement, urine, spittle, pus and blood on the earth,
and the earth is not horrified, humiliated and disgusted because of that, so too, Rahula, develop meditation like the earth.
When you develop meditation like the earth, arisen and disagreeable contacts will not invade your mind and remain.
So the sati has to keep, as it were, like the earth,
right uh to keep it solid to keep it um uh to keep it uh clean of all these things from end from entering into it or a better way of putting that from not allowing the awareness to become engaged in it but to remain objective develop meditation like the water
For when you develop meditation like water, arisen, agreeable and disagreeable contacts will not invade your mind and remain.
Just as people wash clean things and dirty things, excrement your eyes, spittle pus and blood in water,
and the water is not horrified, humiliated, and disgusted.
Because of that, so too, Rahula, develop this meditation like water."
So again, he's talking about the awareness, being aware of something, but not attaching itself to it.
Rahula, develop meditation like fire.
Just as people burn clean things and dirty things, excrement your eyes, spittle pus, blood in fire.
And the fire is not horrified, humiliated and disgusted by that.
Develop your meditation like a fire.
So by doing this, of course, you stop these things invading your mind and remain there.
Develop meditation like the air.
So just as the air blows on clean things and dirty things, on excrement, your eyes, spittle, pus and blood.
And the air is not
Horrified, humiliated and disgusted because of that, so develop your meditation like air.
So these are similes, these are metaphors that give Rahula some idea of how to meditate, how to be objective within oneself, to investigate things, not to allow this awareness to get caught up in what is agreeable and disagreeable.
in the same way with space.
Just as now, just as space is not established anywhere, just as space is not established anywhere, so it's everywhere.
So too, Rahula, meditation is like space.
For when you develop meditation like space, arisen agreeable and disagreeable contracts will not invade your mind and remain.
So there you have an image of space or the awareness, the field of awareness, that space that we're aware of all around us.
Sometimes it's very tiny, what we're aware of, and sometimes it's everything all around us.
So to be spacious like that,
Yeah?
That space does not cling onto anything.
Things move through space, just as things move through our awareness.
So he's used, having got Rahula to look at the body dispassionately as just elements, as you might say when your car, for instance, your mobile breaks and you're really sort of upset about it.
But when you separate it all into those little pieces and you see what's the point of getting upset over a mobile, something like that.
So having done that, he then uses the elements to give us an image of how we ought to meditate.
And then having done that, he then invites Rahula to contemplate the four Brahma Viharas, the four illimitables, loving kindness or love, goodwill, I prefer goodwill, compassion, appreciative joy and equanimity.
And then having done that, right?
So having undermined dispassion for the body, right?
Maybe he's 18, especially.
So he's now dispassionate about the body.
He now develops the heart into these wonderful states.
And when that is done, he can now return to the body to look at the foulness of the body.
And when you develop meditation on foulness, any lust will be abandoned.
So if you remember, we went through this a while back where the Buddha had given a discourse about the foulness of the body to some monks.
But somehow he hadn't softened it.
He hadn't showed them how to balance it.
And they'd gone off and got so upset about the foulness of the body, they'd committed suicide.
And some of them had helped others to commit suicide.
He was really upset by that.
so here here is he's actually undermining that possibility by having developed the good heart so the body is to be let go of as a sensual as a place of sensual delight as such to uh to um to indulging right the delight the body gives is quite natural but to attach to it as this is mine me etc is going to cause problems
especially at this age.
So any lust will be abandoned when you consider the foulness of the body, especially of that body that you're attracted to.
And then he says, after that, develop meditation on the perception of impermanence, because when you do that, the conceit of I am is abandoned.
So that's one good thing about observing impermanence, especially of oneself, the body, you know, getting older and older and all that.
and the fact that one is constantly changing so every self that you create must be somebody else so you start letting go to see impermanence is to take away that sense of continuity which the self demands and then finally you see when he's done all that he can now go back to Sariputta's suggestion a bhikkhu gone to the forest to the root of a tree sits down folds his leg
body erect, establishes mindfulness before him, and begins to practice meditation on the breath.
And then he goes through all, very quickly he goes through how to contemplate the breath, which we have done slightly with the discourse on how to establish mindfulness.
And then he finally says, and even the final in-breath and out-breath, known as this is not known.
This is how mindfulness of breathing is developed and cultivated.
So this is a great fruit and great benefit.
When mindfulness of breathing is developed and cultivated in this way, even the final in-breaths and out-breaths are known as they cease, not unknown.
So in other words, our meditation is always about preparing for death.
Every out-breath, every end of in-breath and every point of the end of an out-breath, these are moments when
These are endings.
And so what the Buddha is saying is that this is also a preparation for our final breaths.
So that is the greater discourse on the advice of Rahula.
I think what we can try to remember is these images of using the elements, but how skillful it is.
He's got a young man who's being tempted
and he first of all tells him to deconstruct the body and then he tells him how to use those very same elements to have some image about what meditation is about and then to develop the heart
with love, with goodwill, compassion, etc.
And then when that's done, to return to the body to see its foulness when lust is abandoned.
Then finally, in the coolness, in the coolness of the new situation, he can develop mindfulness of breathing.
And it would seem that not long after this,
the Buddha gave a further discourse.
This is when he's 18.
So then he gave a further discourse, remember, when he was over 21, when he was actually a fully ordained monastic, on not-self.
That's what it was.
I'm not going to read it because we've been through that sort of thing.
And he becomes fully liberated.
So there's hope for us all.
I hope the discourse has been of some benefit.
And I can only hope that we, all of us, through our devotion to practice, will become liberated sooner rather than later.
Very good.
So we can do a little practice.
Doram kujemi.
Yama kujemi.
Sangam kujemi.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Bodham Saranam Gacchami Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Sangam Saranam Gacchami Tutti Ampi Bodham Saranam Gacchami Tutti Ampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami
Duthiyampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Thathiyampi Budham Saranam Gacchami Thathiyampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Thathiyampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami
Anathipatha Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami Adhinadana Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami Kamesumicacara Vairamani Sikapada Samadhi Ami
musa-vada-vairamani-sikapada-samadhi-ami sura-maraya-maja-pamadakana-vairamani-sikapada-samadhi-ami
So make sure your body is the expression of the enlightened one, the awakened one.
There's that energy in the lower back and the abdomen just lifting you up.
Sitting tall.
Just a moment now just to relax the brow
The jaw.
Lips together, teeth apart.
Shoulders.
Hands on the lap, whatever is comfortable.
And acknowledging that posture.
This body is subject to disease.
This body is of a nature to fall ill.
This body has not gone beyond sickness.
This body is subject to aging.
This body has not gone beyond aging.
This body is now in a process of aging.
This body is subject to death.
This body has not gone beyond death.
This body will die.
There is the unborn, undying, uncreated, uncompounded.
The unconditioned.
True refuge, harbour and home.
Perfect peace and contentment.
Those who are mindful are in the presence of Nirvana.
A moment reflection.
Resolution
So make sure you feel comfortable to practice our contemplations.
Speaking gently into our own hearts.
May I be free of physical pain.
May I be free of mental distress.
May I experience the bliss of liberation.
Bringing to mind someone we know who's having a hard time.
May you be free of physical pain.
May you be free of mental distress.
May you be liberated of all your sufferings.
And there are all those at this moment who are sick and or suffering from mental illness.
People in the process of dying and those who have died and left grieving family, relatives and friends.
People going hungry, homeless and destitute.
Those having to deal with severe personal and interpersonal difficulties.
All those caught up in wars and repressive regimes.
Those being tortured.
And there are those suffering from natural disasters and climate crisis.
All the sentient beings are being cruelly treated and unnecessarily slaughtered.
And all who find life meaningless.
May you be free of physical pain.
May you be free of mental distress.
May you be liberated of all your sufferings.
Radiating our compassion to all beings in all directions.
May all beings be free of physical pain.
May all beings be free of mental distress.
May all beings be liberated of all their sufferings.
Bringing to mind now moments of joyfulness we've experienced today, happiness, peacefulness.
May I be joyful.
May my joyfulness increase.
May I experience the bliss of liberation.
Bring to mind someone we know has caused to be joyful.
May you be joyful.
May your joyfulness increase.
May you experience the bliss of awakening.
And for all those at this moment who are content and happy with their lives, enjoying the warmth of friendships, delighting in art and nature, hobbies and so on, have meaningfulness in their work, enjoy the fruitfulness of their spiritual practice and rejoice in the success of others.
May you be joyful.
May your joyfulness increase.
May you experience the bliss of Nirvana.
Radiating our joy to all beings in all directions.
May all beings be joyful.
May your joyfulness increase.
May you experience the bliss of Nirvana.
Allow these words of the discourse on goodwill to flow through us.
If you are wise and want to reach the state of peace, you need to be upright, responsible, gentle and humble, easily contented, need only a few things.
Not always be busy and have the right sort of work.
You need to guard the senses and be modest.
You do not have to be exclusively attached to only a few people.
You shouldn't do the slightest thing that a wise person could blame you for.
Be thinking always.
May all beings be happy.
Whatever living beings there are, be they weak or strong, big or small, large or slender, living nearby or far away, those who've already been born and those who've yet to be born.
May all beings
without exception be happy be truthful to one another and do not think anyone anywhere is of no value do not wish harm to anyone even when you're angry just as a mother would protect her only child at the risk of her own life let the thought let the warmth of your heart go out to all beings
let your thoughts of love go through the whole world above and below without any barrier with no ill will or hatred whether you are standing walking sitting or lying down so long as you're awake develop this affectionate mindfulness this they say is the noblest way to live and if you do not fall into unskillful ways but live well and develop insight and are no longer attached to all the desires of the senses
then truly you'll never need to be reborn into this world again.
Please join me in the chant, or if you will, using these traditional blessings.
May you be safe, well and happy.
May you live contented in harmony with the world.
kāraṇīyaṁ gātaku salena yāndaṁ santāṁ padāṁ gābhīsāme ca sākaujū ca suhujū ca suvācchocā samuduva nāti māni sāntu sākaujā subhāro ca apākīcocā salāhu kāuti
Santhendro chani bhago cha, apagabokule suvananukito.
Na chakudansa machare kenchi, yena venyu pare upavadeyom.
Sukhino vakemino hantu, sabesatabhavantu sukhitatam.
yekechipana bhutati tasavatavarava anavasasam digavaye mahantavavajimarasakalukatulam ditavayeva aditaye cadurevasantiyavidure bhutavastambhavesivara
Sābe sātā pāvāntu sukhi tātā.
Nāpāro parā nīkū pētā, Nāti mānyatā kata cīnēn kēncī.
Vīyāro sāna patīgā sānyā, Nānyamānyā sādukā gīcēnā.
Mātāyatā nīyāṅ kūtāṅ, Gāyusāy kāpūtāṅ ānu nākē.
Hey wampi sabba bhutensu, mana sambhava yeyaparimalam.
Metencha sabbalokasmi, mana sambhava yeyaparimalam.
Udanga docha tiriyanca, asampadanga veranga sapadam.
Tīṭṭhāṁ ca rāṇiṣṭhino vāsāyāṇo vāyāvatāsavigāṭhānido.
Hei tāṁ satiṅgāditeyā brahmāṅgētāṁ vihārāṅgītā mahū.
Dītiṁ ca anupāgamaḥ sila vātāsānena-sampāna.
kame suvene agedam nahi jatuka-bhaseyam punaretiti
May all beings be happy.
very good uh another very fruitful day without any doubt uh don't forget from now to fall asleep is also part of our practice putting something beautiful into the heart slip away into sweet oblivion awaking to take full con to take full advantage of the day may you sleep peacefully